oh boy how's it going I'm a huge fan of
yours um and I what I really wanted to
say was I find it really hard to have a
civil discussion with people from the
opposite side because I want to learn
more about their point of view and
sometimes they learn more of my point of
view what do you think the best way
about going about kind of you know
having the groundwork like alright you
know let's present each other's side and
actually discuss it and not let's
devolve into a screaming match I mean
the first thing you have to do is you
actually have to do a little bit of
assessment as to whether the person
you're talking to wants to have a
conversation with you they're only a few
reasons to have a conversation with
somebody on the left one is to actually
have a discussion you might find
somebody on the Left who actually wants
to exchange ideas kind of rare but it
happens you could also have a situation
where you just want to hone your own
ideas so you're arguing for your own
purposes or you're debating somebody on
a stage in which case your goal is
basically to accumulate that person as
badly as possible but you have to decide
which conversation is which and also you
know this I mean everybody knows this
but they don't apply it they get into
Facebook fight and then five posts in
and an hour later they're like oh I wish
I hadn't done that thing with the first
post is this the thing that's going to
help me or this the thing that's just a
waste of time and I don't know if it's
if I can ask after work a picture with
you after the conversation I'll try to
stick around as long as I can yeah thank
you
[Applause]
hey Ben I'm 14 years old
I'm a huge fan I'm from Rochester and
I'm a conservative and the New York
public school like education system
makes it really hard for me to spread my
like conservative viewpoints like my
friends my community and as you can see
my shirt says bench biro 20 and I was
just wondering if at any point in the
future could we possibly see you running
for office of any kind so a few years
ago I probably would have said yes
because it was something I was
interested in watching as public figures
get absolutely destroyed personally it
makes me less likely to do it I think
our politics is such right now the
decent people and I try to consider
myself decent decent people are sort of
being driven out of the public square
people who have no shame or honor I
think are being encouraged to to run for
office on every side of the aisle you
know I could see a possibility sometime
in the future it won't be in 2020 but it
but I appreciate the sentiment all right
thank you
[Applause]
I've been I'm a freshman at UB from
Dutchess County you talked about divorce
rates and how divorce rates have been
increasing this country country since
the 1970s and just kind of alluded to
that as evidence of the failure of
radical it sort of leveled off since
like the the 2000s like the early 2000s
but yes they're still higher than they
were in the 50s and for right couldn't
that also simply because of the fact
that women are now more
socioeconomically able to be independent
than men like how can you say that
radical feminism cause divorces and also
ignore the fact that possibly it was
just that women became able to be
independent the airport they started
divorce more because they would be
becoming an economic and economically
independent in the same period as they
were getting divorced is they were
getting married meaning that these
aren't twenty-year marriages that are
breaking up these are like five-year
marriages that are breaking up which
suggests to me a mental shift that's
taking place in the nature of how we
think about marriage rather than
socioeconomic status being the indicator
but learning that I suppose that
economics could tie into this except for
the fact that people who are higher
income tend to stay married more often
than people who are lower income right
so that sort of undercuts the argument a
little bit meaning that if you're if
you're richer you tend to be married
longer on average people who are poorer
tend to get divorce where did you get
that statistical Census Bureau
[Applause]
hi Ben I just want to say I'm a huge fan
of the show I got the mug I'm a
subscriber awesome I'm overflowing this
week they left us tears how dreadful
tell me they never have to fill it up
the question I wanted to ask is after
the whole I guess there's no better way
to put it with debacle involving the the
appointment of Justice Kavanagh to the
bench do you think this is a moment
where Americans is like as a society are
going to start to maybe come back
together and try to establish norms or
or is this just a moment where our
politics are just gonna further polarize
and we're just going to start to tear a
part even harder at the seams number one
I love your optimism I'm by nature a
pessimist which means I'm always right
eventually so it's so my feeling is that
when you see people who are screaming
and trying to pry open 13 done ton
bronze doors in front of the Supreme
Court as Brett Kavanaugh is being sworn
in inside and then you have full
editorials in the New York Times saying
that white women are racist because they
supported Brett Kavanaugh which I just
don't even understand no I don't think
this this rift is gonna be healed any
time soon in fact I think that the book
that I'm right that I have coming out
next year is largely about why this
giant rift has opened up in America at a
time when we are historically wealthy
what we really don't have any major
foreign crises on our hands
we don't have a lot in common anymore as
the sad truth a nation is defined by a
common history a common culture a common
set of goals common institutions all of
those things are being torn asunder by
serious divides that we have about how
we view our own central principles and
we used to be unified by a belief in God
given rights and limited government
obviously that doesn't unify us we used
to be unified and by belief in
judeo-christian virtue that no longer
unifies us we used to be unified by a
belief that America was essentially a
good place even though we never lived up
to our full promise even that I think is
no longer a unifying principle which is
why we now have people who see American
history is in Howard Zinn fashion it's a
long history of suffering and pain and
patriarchal institution institutional
discrimination if those bridges don't if
those gaps don't get bridged I think
that we're headed toward a schism that
is gonna grow larger and larger over
time I don't see how the only thing I
could see is that eventually just
disgust with the way this works
means that forget politics somebody
who's felt to be fundamentally decent
ends up running for office and you get a
spate of those people running for office
and then it's about voting for the
decency of the people as opposed to a
particular political agenda thank you so
much for coming
[Applause]
hello Ben how are you doing tonight
doing okay how are you so I'm a liberal
and well thank you for coming I
appreciate it yeah
but at the same time on the topic of
free speech I consider myself a
libertarian it's why you're a liberal
and not a leftist you see whenever
whenever I do my speeches right it's
always liberal versus leftist liberals
are people who disagree with me on
politics but aren't trying to attack me
with machetes and leftists are people
who disagree with me on politics and are
trying to shut down my speech all right
so what I want to ask you about so me
personally I disagree with many social
networks move to ban Alex Jones from
their platforms and I think it's a
violation of the spirit of the First
Amendment but in comparison with that I
was asking would you agree with me that
by the NFL stopping Kaepernick from
kneeling is that also a violation of the
First Amendment the spirit of it in some
sense and do you believe that a
corporation has the right to do what it
wants knowing about that so there are
several actual questions number one do
corporations have the right to do what
they want yes Facebook and the NFL that
the rights do what they want right
they're private corporations they do now
the more important question is the first
one you asked about sort of the spirit
of the First Amendment I think that the
real question is what these corporations
are designed to do so social networks
were originally designed to facilitate
discourse between various political
sides that's what they're designed to do
the NFL was not really designed to do
that the NFL presents a product right
the NFL's product is what is on the
field if the NFL were to find people for
stuff that they said on Twitter then I
would suggest that the NFL was was doing
something wrong for the NFL to say
you're affecting our viewership and the
product that we present that's a
different thing just as if Alex Jones
worked for CNN and he and he went on air
and he started talking about Satan get
behind me I'm unbuttoning my shirt now
look at this underneath I got another
shirt right if he started doing that
routine
and CNN
[Applause]
I think at that point CNN has every
right to do whatever they want with him
so the for the corporate question the
question is what is the corporation
designed to do and and the the lie of
Facebook and Twitter was that they were
basically going to be essentially free
open networks for discourse and then it
turns out that there are more publishers
they're more like my site or CNN right
trying to add editorial guidance what I
think is that a Facebook and Twitter if
they want to ban people they should do
so based on threats of violence slightly
you know actual legal slander like that
that's where they should drive me why
not add stuff we don't like because Alex
Jones is it nutball so I have a quick
follow-up you don't mind just sure so
then would you disagree with perhaps Tim
Tebow's right to kneel in prayer on the
field yeah if they'd find him for his
for kneeling in prayer on the field then
they would have every right to do that
do
[Applause]
- I want to start off and say I'm a huge
fan of yours and we love the possibility
to get a picture with you and I'm truly
hoping you run for presidency in 2024
although if you wanted to secure my vote
during your campaign and buy some
absolute miracle I'd have to see you
defeat Ocasio Cortez in the debate
calling your dude that brings me my
question with college campuses becoming
increasingly overwhelmed by professors
with leftist teachings and rhetoric I
like many other young conservatives feel
my back against the wall and I wanting
to share my conservative views
especially on sensitive subjects for
running the risk of being ostracized by
a mob and my classmates what sort of
advice me gives this so my advice has
always been to be practical meaning that
you have to decide what the risk benefit
analysis looks like exactly the
cost-benefit analysis so when I was in
law school there were certain professors
who were really great about debate and
people on the Left who really enjoyed
the fact that we go back and forth and
that was wonderful I enjoy and then
there are certain professors who weren't
and those were the professors where I
basically keep quiet because my grade
was more important to me than making a
point everyone was gonna forget 20
seconds later if I wanted to talk to
students outside of class I would do it
then I that's always been my view I've
never felt like you need to sacrifice
your grade or sacrifice your future to
make a point in class that everyone is
gonna forget 15 seconds later except for
the professor who's going to grade you
down the best path is to speak truth
whenever possible and when not possible
don't get good grades make lots of money
threaten to withhold alumni funding and
then because discrimination in the
classroom obviously shouldn't be
approved by the administration thanks
man thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
hey Ben I'm a big fan during the
meet-and-greet when you came here
earlier and you touched on the issue of
abortion and I'll just says like to ask
that question because I did a debate on
abortion in high school even though I
don't necessarily agree with that was on
the pro side and I took it as an
opportunity to learn from the other side
and although I can say that one of their
main talking points was how if abortion
was made it legal that people would just
get illegal abortions and then twice the
amount of people would die in the
instance of that but then I also said
well that's not my issue my issue is
with how it's almost weaponized like to
say like the left kind of weaponized it
where it's like if you don't agree with
the borscht like abortion is amazing
thing and amazing right and amazing
power but then I'm like it's actually a
really tough decision it's not something
I'm going to go celebrate and say I'm
really like it's awesome it's a
beautiful thing and like why how do you
think the left did that way I think the
left actually came to a logical
realization which is that safe legal and
rare is an untenable political position
so that was the Clintonian position in
the 90s they said abortion should be
safe legal and rare well when you say
that it should be rare you're
undercutting safe and legal actually or
at least legal right because the problem
is if you say it's rare you're
acknowledging that there is moral
content to the action you are taking
which raises the question as to why it
should be legal right so in other words
if it's what the left says and it's just
removal of a polyp why should it be rare
I don't think polyp removal should be
rare I think anyone else believes that
either but when the left acknowledges
there's a moral content to what it is
that they're doing they get themselves
into a rhetorical trap so instead it
turns into shout your abortion be proud
of your abortion I'd be proud that it
was like I it was like a step into
womanhood to get an abortion and anybody
I think with any moral sense can see how
terrible that is but the left is made
you know people who are left on abortion
have made a crusade and a sacrament out
of abortion in a way that they hadn't
even when I was you know in in high
school so it's it's pretty incredible
and pretty pretty horrifying and that's
why I've always thought I mean on Fox I
did my election special on Sunday and on
Fox I did a monologue
at the very end of the show about
abortion and in the end the monologue on
abortion I think the best way to fight
against the pro-choice position the
pro-abortion position is to actually
just show
of what it is that this baby is okay
because there's not a single Democrat in
the in the Senate or in the House of
Representatives that I know of who would
vote to save a baby at the at the
twelfth week or fourteenth week that's
not that's not so you can feel the baby
kicking
I know I've had to him yeah this is this
is this is crazy town a crazy talk and
the facts and the science happen to be
on our side one of my pet peeves on this
issue is when people say oh you only say
that cuz you're religious you only say
that because of the Bible
I have never invoked the Bible or God in
any argument about abortion yeah I got
that a lot too it's idiotic consider
yeah it's just it's a way for them to
avoid the necessary scientific
conclusion from the fact that human life
begins in fertilization they don't want
to talk science they accuse you being a
religious bigot even though you're
actually not invoking God I do hate that
word they just say it's a clump of cells
it's just what I say is you are
technically a clump of cells as well
just a walking because they are you see
you're you're slightly more develops
clump of cells but that doesn't mean
that you're the like none of none of the
other arguments hold the viability
argument doesn't hold there plenty of
human beings who are not viable outside
of outside support from machines or a
pacemaker we don't we don't suggest that
they can now be terminated there are
lots of people who don't have proper
brain function and babies in orbits and
or fetuses or embryos which are going to
develop proper brain function to suggest
that those babies are somehow lesser
because of the improper brain function
for a temporary period not even for
permanent period that is obviously
casting aspersions and people who don't
necessarily have full brain function
it's very difficult to make an
intellectually consistent case for why
abortion ought to be treated as as
morally ambiguous I have a tough time
with it thank you man
[Applause]
so I'm Robert I'm one of the coastal
liberals as you say um I mean I've been
watching you for years now and I'm like
I read your book on the arguments to
fight against people like me and I feel
bad is like for the most part the people
have been arguing against your and
nearly as elegant or eloquent as they
should be but I'd like to ask so one of
your points you very strongly make is
that it's unfair for you know people
like me to label you as like a racist or
a bigot um just as like a smear tactic
but if you ever acknowledge that like
maybe it's not a smear tactic but it's
based on things you've said so like for
example like on the israel-palestine
conflict you know you called the Arabs
yeah you already know I'm going to say
you know yeah so well you say written
several full columns about it yeah I'm
sorry about how you people don't read
the follow up tweets right I've read
some of the tweets and the tweets were
just as bad I mean you say a lot of
things that are just like races right
but then if I call you're racist then
you defend it by saying like I didn't
read enough right so that's what I was
gonna say forgive me okay fine so give
me give me give me my racist tweets in
context okay well yeah you came prepared
right go go do it um so you said um the
Arabs like to bomb crap and live in open
sewage there's not a difficulty oh you
oh you before that said Israel's
Israelis like to build did you did you
like Gigi okay now the file was because
you said the follow-ups didn't make any
better well this is separate of things
that you said no no I want to follow up
to that one now Thomas if you have them
sure um do you mind if I what you do
that what is that you mind if I continue
while you do that um well I'd like to
take him one by one so why don't why we
do this why we delay that one until the
end well I look up from the podium in
front of 600 people you've also said
[Applause]
so on that particular issue he also said
that the Arab Palestine populace is by
and large by and large density
constitutes the most evil population in
the face of the planet before you said
that you've never brought up religion
when it comes to abortion but I don't
think that you've avoided religion when
it comes to the Israeli conflict and I
don't know that you can be completely
unbiased in the issue given that you
know well I can be unbiased on the
subject that Palestinians have elected
three terrorist governments to form a
unity government with the stated goal of
the destruction of the State of Israel
and the murder of all Jews in the area
so that I can be relatively unbiased on
as far as the idea that the Palestinian
population
as far as the idea of the palestinian
population is more evil than other
populations they certainly hold more
evil views than other populations by
poll statistics by how many you buy how
many palestinians approve of terrorist
acts by how many palestinians voted for
an actual terror group hamas and another
actual terror group is Palestinian
Authority and another actual terror
group the Islamic Jihad okay so I don't
think that all people all views are
equal and I don't think that people who
hold the evil views are necessarily good
I mean I'm sorry if the polls don't
support the idea that everyone is
equally wonderful but everyone is not
equally wonderful okay I'm looking up
these statements you know so um like to
give me a second you've continued you
deny secular Zionism and you okay so
here I'll finish that one then okay
ready there are many many Christian and
Muslim Arabs who are wonderful people
just not the ones who oppose it Israeli
Israel Arab conflict that would be the
response within the same Twitter thread
okay in the post re Israelis versus
Arabs I wrote about Arabs who take part
in the israeli-arab conflict is anyone
who can read knows hashtag dumbasses
okay quote I think it has much more to
do with the fact that the Palestinian
leadership supported by the Palestinian
population uses millions for terror I
should have been more specific Arabs who
actively seek Israel's destruction those
would be the follow-up tweets does that
sound like a genocide Albania to you or
does it tell Mike I'm specifically
labeling a group of people who have
called for Israel's destruction I like
to point out that you're not a racist
but they're dumbasses and those you're
allowed to insult them yes because
someone called it races without evidence
they are definitionally a dumber what is
genocide
[Applause]
what is genocide like the after when a
so you said that you you want to be like
Churchill right and after the Allies
when they moved the german-speaking
polish out of Poland so now you're
talking about a column I wrote when I
was nineteen years old that I that I
actually thought that I'd morally
abhorrent denounce myself I think six
years ago you and have repeatedly and
have repeatedly said was a bad column
that I wrote when I was nineteen years
old okay okay so more time like do you
want to only get a drink sometime like a
well is that saying what we're gonna get
it like a non-alcoholic drink sometime
because I really I know that I got a
poster but let me just say this for
everything that you're going to say I've
addressed literally every one of those
points I have a column that I put out
probably only a few months ago and the
literal title of it is so here's a giant
list of all the dumb stuff I've ever
done don't worry I'll keep updating it I
didn't get that one my research I
apologize but if I've missed represent
like I did my research wasn't it would
be so thorough because I was pretty uh
last-minute decision to start like
really going in China ask you a question
and again that's totally fine and I
appreciate you coming and I appreciate
you asking me the questions but if the
notion is that I'm a racist before you
actually read all my response in the
racism from part I also like the
transgender like you don't believe in
transgenders in life that's not I don't
know that means I don't believe in
transgenders I mean a transgender people
exist yeah you've seen their gender and
sex are the same thing I said the gender
and sex are linked I've said that
femininity and masculinity are linked to
male anymore just before you so they're
right there are two genders I don't
believe there are 1000 genders and if I
think that if you're defining gender as
just a random series of societal
constructs and there aren't two genders
there are infinite numbers of genders
because everybody is a mix of feminine
and masculine
so while restricted to 70 genders make
it six billion genders since we all have
our unique mix of what male and female
constitute and I don't ban by I and yes
I don't think that there can be such a
thing as a male in a female's body I
don't think there is a female in a
male's body and I find the logic to
support that and the science to support
that utterly lacking yeah so you know
again I'd be happy to get a
non-alcoholic beverage with you and
discussion more forward
thank you for coming thank you
[Applause]
hi my name is John and I am a senior
doing a political science major and I
would like to ask the question in
regards to this is my first time ever
doing it so everything okay okay you
stated that you didn't care about
people's concern about the Browning of
America which in my opinion is
essentially not caring about the issue
of illegal immigration
no and sorry go ahead and yet you
support Israel's ethnos state by stating
that Judaism must be preserved since
elements like this uphold Jewish
national identity and culture which I
don't mind but the fact that you know
you don't care about the demographic
change in America is kind of concerning
because you know we're all Americans
here right and you know I the question
is do you want our nation to end up like
a third world country such as Brazil or
a disaster like Germany and Sweden right
now okay so Brazil is a second world
country
technically it's a developing country
it's not like a fully underdeveloped
country or a failed state and why why is
there a far-right candidate winning at
the moment I mean if you want to argue
Brazilian politics I agree that
Brazilian policies have been dominated
by the far left but I'm not sure that
that's of tremendous interest let's talk
about the first question okay when I say
I don't care about the Browning of
America what I mean is I don't care
about ethnicity it doesn't make any
difference to me the only thing that
makes a difference to me is the ideals
of the people who are coming across the
border now when people say I am Pro
illegal immigration I do not know where
in the hell they would possibly get that
this seems to when people repeat when
people repeatedly say stuff like this
like and I see this meme all the time oh
superhero cares about a Jewish ethnos
day but he but he doesn't care about it
legal immigration I was further right
than Donald Trump was in the last
election cycle on illegal immigration I
opposed the 2006 amnesty deal I opposed
the 2000 2010 amnesty deal I have I've
consistently been anti-illegal
immigration I supported the wall this is
just a lie the idea that I'm probably
legal immigration is not true in the
slightest what I have said is that we
ought to
deal with how to stop the influx of
illegal immigration and then deal with
the people who are here and separate off
the two issues and when it comes to the
folks who are here illegally what we
should do is we should assess those
folks in the same way we assess
everybody else coming into the country
are they going to ad economically to the
country and culturally to the country
are they gonna make the country a better
place are they gonna make a country a
worse place and that involves
assimilation now as far as the idea of
the Jewish ethnos state I don't care
very much about at all actually about
Jewish ethnicity Jewish ethnicity makes
no difference to me what does make a
difference to me is Jewish ideals
because I care about judeo-christian
ideals in the United States and I care
about Jewish ideals in Israel which is
why I don't care and I'm very happy that
thousands tens of thousands of Ethiopian
Jews who are black were flown to Israel
to become Israelis I'm very happy that
tens of thousands of Russian Jews who
were Russian were flown from Russia to
become Israelis my wife is Moroccan
right she's Moroccan Israeli so this
idea that that it's it's about ethnicity
as opposed to ideology or ideas is just
not true
then the amazing thing about Judaism
just like most other religions is you
can become one okay I can't become a
black man there's no way for me to do it
right I can become a Christian you could
become a Jew right this means that there
are ideological systems that you can buy
into that allow you entry and I believe
that the United States should operate
the same way you can become an American
if you buy into Central American ideals
but I'm not going to pretend that I care
whether a whether a bunch of people who
are Pro America and pro-american ideals
come from Cuba versus coming from
Britain I understand
I respect your beliefs and your white to
hold them then I just think that person
I have a question tree why are you ik
waiting white or race with culture why
are you saying usually the same thing
well because most you know you know Jew
Jews mostly practice Judaism and just
like you know
actually most Jews actually don't
practice Judaism technically speaking
but is it mostly most of them are part
of that so it's only a like a minority
of people that want to convert to
Judaism which I don't mind okay and it's
only minority of people who want to
become Americans or sure or we should
let in if they want to become Americans
enough I'm asking not about Israel I'm
asking you about America okay I'm asking
about America so you're saying that you
object the so-called Browning of America
why no I I'm just saying I got ejected
illegal immigration which so do i but
your original question was about the
Browning of America yeah why you know
basically you know it's basically like
the open borders you know I agree with
you about going on right now I agree
with you about illegal immigration I
asked you about not about that I'm
asking you about the Browning of America
phrase cuz that's what you objected to I
said I don't care about the ground whole
entire culture is changing at the moment
just so you know I understand that
culture is changing at the moment but I
do not think that culture and race are
inseparable I don't think that brown
people are less capable of becoming
American or black people are less
capable will become in America
and I agree that you know when people
come to this country including you know
myself and my family who immigrated here
illegally in the in the 80s and I think
that you know that people that do it if
they follow the law and they assimilate
they should do that right I mean let's
put this way can we agree on this I care
about the liberalizing of America and
the destruction of American values I
don't care about what the nature of the
people who look like is who believe in
American values those people are my
family
everybody who doesn't believe in those
American ideals is not alright thank you
it's been the last pledge from ladies
rolling let's be the last question
big man what's up with you has gone dude
okay so my question is well first I'm
gonna kind of need to give you this
hammer your enormous dude you can build
this much better than I can I look like
one of the one of the dwarves from seven
from Snow White and the Seven Dwarves my
go mining or something appreciate that
um so first of all kind of paraphrase
another speaker who kind of operates
along the same tone in America Jordan
Peterson dr. Jordan Peterson
[Applause]
so one of the things that he often talks
about is at the basis or the premise of
the ongoing debate between conservatism
versus liberalism is that at the basis
of each conservative the conservatism is
like the the protection of the hierarchy
whereas on the liberal side is more so
the protection and promotion of
egalitarianism and so my question to you
is one thing that he makes clear is that
both sides are necessary for our ideal
in a country that moves forward at a
fast pace as the United States has has
done and so my question to you is it
seems as though you have a more hostile
you have such a hostility towards
liberals and and left this whereas I
don't often hear you at all say that
there's anything that you can learn from
their side in his book twelve rooms
alive when the chapters is assumed that
the person in which you're speaking with
has something to offer you as far as
intellectually that you may learn from
them so my question to you is I guess
what is your position like do you feel
as though a liberal obviously a liberal
but liberals in general or less in
general have anything to bring to the
table from an ideology standpoint or
intellectually I mean passion for
changes obviously it can be a good thing
when directed in the proper channel
the as you say the the left's focus on
egalitarianism is good so long as it is
focused on the equal application of
Rights not on the false attempts to
override biology and natural hierarchy
so I think Jordan would agree with me on
the idea that if you run up if you butt
up against a natural hierarchy or if you
butt up against natural differences
because I don't think every difference
is a hierarchy if you brought up against
natural differences but up against
reality trying to override reality with
artificial equality is going to be a
giant failure and can as Jordan would
say murder millions in the in the
process right that's what Jordan thinks
communism was it was basically there are
differences between human beings failure
of respect those differences is what we
in the name of equality is what leads to
the gulags so while Jordan is you know
Jordan I think he's he's a little bit
less robust in the language that he uses
with regard to left he's he's just as
anti left with regard to the focus on
hardcore egalitarianism where the left
so I I do think and I do make a
distinction between as I've said
liberals and the left is a far more
since aureus force and they want to
censor a lot more they're a lot more
traumatically I want to control a lot
more from the top
people who are liberals who are arguing
over the proper scope of government
particularly is there I think there's
plenty to learn and I think you can have
fulsome exchanges about the nature of
what sort of social welfare state can be
supported or is appropriate and you can
have a data exchange on that sort of
thing
where you can't really have an exchange
is when you're running up against is
when people are falsifying the fact as
they only may say that men and women are
exactly the same for example so so I
appreciate the critique and I'll try to
take that to heart and I think that and
I will acknowledge also that I think
that folks had a lot more to learn from
the left in the 1960s than they do now
because the country has moved in a lot
of very good ways since the 1960s and in
some bad ways since the 1960s fair
enough thank you thanks a lot
can ask another question
we have another one okay and this more
this has to do with the whole you know
national anthem in players kneeling
during games in the NFL and so my
question is this is I feel that
regardless of whether you agree with the
Act or not someone taking a knee during
the national anthem at the beginning of
a football game I believe that if you if
you don't say okay I disagree with the
Act I don't think it's the right place I
don't think it's the right whatever the
case may be however I agree with it in
so much as I would like to protect that
into votes individuals freedom of speech
and my question is I don't hear what you
certainly are a lot of anyone on the
conservative side or right side as you
would call it as someone may call it
defending sin okay look I don't agree
with it but I agree with that person's
freedom of speech in that moment or it
depends on the forum so this is a public
university I have a right to speak here
right there's a difference between that
and for example DePaul University so
DePaul University is a private
university last year I think is last
year I had to Paul invited me to speak
really some of the students did the
administration said I couldn't and when
I showed up on campus they threatened to
arrest me
I didn't sue the university because they
have a right to do that I think they're
wrong I think they're foolish but they
have a right to do that so colin
kaepernick does not have the right to
kneel on the sidelines of in private NFL
event if he wants to kneel in a park
welcome according to WHO well he doesn't
he doesn't have the legal right he can't
sue the NFL to force them all so he
can't sue the NFL sir so so that that's
the distinction that I'm making when a
comment like if Colin Kaepernick were to
come here like right here
you know and like after the event that
we haven't organized wants to kneel on
the stage all day long that's totally
fine it's a public university can do
what he wants you know I so time place
and manner restrictions are a thing and
so is private versus public so I'll
defend Colin Kaepernick's right to say
whatever the hell he wants in any public
area so long as he's not violating the
rights of private property owners to
control their property because they do
have rights at like he couldn't come
into my living room and just kneel on
the floor do you think they did the
conversation is based around the fact
that the NFL is a private organization
or is based a found based around the
fact that they feel that that action
disrespects our military in that moment
because the national anthem is so so
slightly NFL I think the NFL handled
this in the worst way possible which is
the certain message
and not other messages there were on the
same page right so like a few years ago
there were a bunch of guys in Missouri
who did the hands up don't shoot symbol
coming at the Senate the st. Louis Rams
they came out of the tunnel doing that
hands up don't shoot
they weren't fine nothing happened if
the NFL wants to set a standard that
you're not allowed to make political
statements during the games or in the
warm-ups or something totally cool but
if they're going to be inconsistent in
the application of those standards then
I've got a bit of a problem
with them and I think that Roger Goodell
has done a terrible job with that it's
and you know how you know this because
David Stern actually banned people from
sitting for the national anthem in 1996
with my fluid abdul rove and nothing
happened he set the standard that was
the end of it if you want to go protest
don't protest here go protest somewhere
else and nobody cared but that's really
not even a lot I look the larger issue
about Kaepernick is you know whether it
is appropriate generally for people to
know for the national anthem or whether
we should be insulted by that you know
my feeling is that it's generally not
appropriate but you have having a right
to do something does not make it the
appropriate or right thing to do I don't
think that kneeling for the national
anthem is either smart politics or the
right thing to do cuz there are certain
things that still have to unify us like
the idea the country is based on good
foundations and if he wanted to kneel
for the national anthem outside a police
station I think that would be a lot more
useful for his for his supposed cause
then you know taking millions and
millions of dollars of contracts from
Nike to pretend to be a social justice
warrior I'm very skeptical of Colin
Kaepernick I think there are a lot of
people who actually care about these
issues and have studied the issues and
don't wear socks with pictures of cops
as pigs on them just want to say thank
you and I I agree that if that was going
to happen Colin Kaepernick may not have
been the best proponent the best
individual to make that stand in that
situation I appreciate thank you so much
for coming
hey how's it going
good evening mr. Shapiro my name is
chanel Powell nice to meet you you too
so I'm a liberal in view those are my
views and well again thank you for
coming I appreciate people who disagree
are you coming to our campus and
speaking with us so I came here
essentially out of support for yeah and
I also came here to listen and learn
from you from what you're saying I think
it's important to see opposite sides and
discuss right but my question to you is
how do we essentially bridge the gap
from two different points of view how
are we able to meet in the middle
by listening I mean essentially you want
the same thing we want better for a
country and better for our people
everyone in this room is our people how
do we take care of them how do we meet
in the middle and take care of them well
I mean I think that we actually have to
determine to be completely Frank whether
we do want the same thing because I
think that sometimes people on left and
right think they want the same thing in
vague terms like better country but we
actually determine what better country
looks like so do we want a country where
there's more freedom to rise and fall
economically or we want a country with
more enforced rigidity of income for
example that's an actual difference in
goal do we want a country where men and
women are free to pursue whatever lives
that they want encouraged to pursue
pursue pursue virtue at the same time or
do we see that encouragement by social
groups to virtue as a sort of block and
check on freedom you know there are
certain there are certain areas where we
have to clarify exactly what we think an
ideal America looks like my ideal
America is basically John Stuart Mill's
America you get to do whatever you want
you wave your hand around as much as you
want and so you hit somebody in the face
but that is also contingent on all of us
trying to act virtuously toward our
neighbors so I think that the great
genius of the founders that they were
balancing the the sort of European
enlightenment view of Liberty with a
more traditional list view of what
private citizenry looked like which was
a duty based private citizenry of duty
to your neighbor not based on what
government tells you to do I'm not sure
that that's what the ideal America looks
like necessarily for a lot of folks on
the Left who feel perhaps that
individual rights need to take a
backseat to collective solutions right
so for example my deal America is not in
America where the government forces
doctors to provide care
price because I think that a free market
a free market solution is not just
better for healthcare I think it's more
moral I think that a consent based
society is in more moral society and
economics a lot of folks on the left
hand well consent based society won't
get us to universal healthcare right so
these are these are serious
conversations and serious discussions I
think the way that we can have a
conversation is actually by sitting in
defining terms so very few conversations
begin with the defining of the terms
they sort of start with second-order
conversations so instead of saying what
do you want healthcare to look like in
America what are your competing rights
and values instead we start with we all
want the same thing and therefore
nationalized healthcare or we all want
the same thing and therefore complete
privatization we might not actually want
the same thing so you might want to
start with that discussion first what do
you want to see so what I would like to
see in some of these areas is more
individual freedom and then social
social networks outside of government
picked up the slack that's what my ideal
America looks like for a lot of folks on
the Left they don't trust the social
networks they think that the government
has to come in and and take care from
the top down these are fundamentally
different views of the country and I'm
not sure that they are completely
bridgeable we can have conversations
about them but in the end I think the
clarity is sometimes preferable to to
agreement in ambiguity I appreciate your
time thank you thanks so much thank you
so much I really appreciate it
[Music]
[Applause]